el último frente contra el coronavirus
en china escucho una turística macro
ciudad de 10 millones de habitantes
situada a escasa media hora al sur de
shanghái y conocida como la venecia
china por sus célebres canales son ya
ocho casos de la nueva variante omicron
todos ellos localizados en trabajadores
de un parque industrial la ciudad ha
ordenado ya el protocolo de seguridad ha
cerrado bares restaurantes y escuelas ha
prohibido las reuniones en lugares
públicos ha suspendido las líneas de
autobús de larga distancia y exige una
autorización para salir de la ciudad es
el mayor susto que sufre china desde que
empezaron los juegos olímpicos de
invierno de pekín que han sido diseñados
para evitar que el virus salte a la
población local los miles de
participantes viven en un circuito
cerrado y son sometidos a pruebas pcr
cada día se han detectado ya más de 400
contagios casi todos en las horas
siguientes de arte
en pekín las autoridades han calificado
el sistema de un gran éxito y hoy han
informado por primera vez de que no se
ha detectado ni un solo caso positivo